li can you share some stories of writers
that were unwrapped that went to then
become wrapped and worked in television
of course there's too many good stories
there's the problem but one of my
favorite stories that in that is a story
something happened to a client of mine
this past year this is a client a writer
whom I met through UCLA we started
working together he then started taking
classes at a program called script
Anatomy that I'm a big fan of really
perfected his work wrote a fantastic
pilot that ended up actually coming in
second place in the prestigious UCLA
contest using this pilot he found a
manager who decided to shop the pilot
which is highly unlikely today to shop a
pilot from a brand-new writer but he
found a manager a very well-known and
well-respected manager who took out the
script they went on a bunch of meetings
and bunch of networks ultimately at that
point nothing had come of it but he
continued to network pretty aggressively
and in a pretty focused fashion he is
Latino and he went to a panel of Latino
writers and had prepped for the panel
before it had happened and so he walked
in knowing a little bit about each one
of the panelists he tried to communicate
with three of the four those three he
couldn't really make any sort of
connection with but the fourth writer he
really hit it off with ultimately he
felt like he didn't want to stalk the
writer he didn't want to be the guy
going
can you read my script so he befriended
him on Facebook and Twitter and that was
the end of it a few months passed and he
realized that this writer was teaching a
class at writing pad which is a writing
program and said you know I'm going it's
it's a prep class for the television
fellowships I want to go sign up for the
class because as part of this class this
writer is going to have to read my work
the writer read his work called him up
and said hey I think I know of an
opportunity for you it turned out the
opportunity was staffing on American
crime season three the most prestigious
show on
or television based on the writers
personal story the writer went on to
meet with the executive producer of the
show and then went on to have a call
with John Ridley he had no in the room
experience
he was then called in to meet with ABC
Disney's inclusion Department which
subsidizes the fellowship they all
signed off on him and three days before
the room opened he got the call that he
is staffing on the show I really love
this story because I feel like it takes
the onus of getting that first job out
of the agent or managers hand the writer
is now signed with CAA writing
feverishly seeing him tomorrow at 8
o'clock morning you know hard at work he
he just finished his season of American
crime where he had a co-write so he had
a he had a co-written by credit on his
own episode you know just as euphoric as
can be love the experience but it's a
writer who really made it happen for
himself rather than saying okay I have
an agent I have a manager I'm gonna sit
on my hands and wait for something like
that to happen so I particularly love
that story because it just shows you
what a writer who is smart about
networking can do for himself and you
know he went from a complete unknown
taking classes in UCLA to a raft and
working writer
you